cette semaine on vous parle de la
stratégie de l'industrie pétrolière pour
alimenter le doute sur les changements
climatiques pour moi ya quelque chose de
fondamentalement maloney a toujours
essayé de dire il en faut plus plus de
connaissances on lève le voile sur des
documents qui montrent l'hypocrisie de
l'industrie qui savait depuis longtemps
que ces produits pouvaient poser les
changements climatiques sans espaces
d'anciens ministres de l'environnement
se vide le coeur sur leur faiblesse
devant la puissance des lobbys
pétroliers
par exemple le géant exxon qui s'est
battu contre l'adoption de règles plus
sévères pour lutter contre les gaz à
effet de serre
quand j'étais à l'intérieur et je
luttais ça me faisait vraiment frustré
parce que nous avions promis de faire
ces choses-là ici marie maude denis
bienvenue à anka
été 1988 l'amérique du nord suffoque
sous une vague de chaleur exceptionnelle
et le grand public entend parler pour la
première fois d'une grave menace
environnementale devant le congrès
américain
un scientifique de la nasa james hansen
affirme que l'effet de serre est
détectée et qu'il modifie déjà notre
climat à toronto au canada
c'est une conférence internationale qui
sonne alarme vinci at-on appris d'une
augmentation de quelques degrés
seulement des températures du globe
pouvait faire plusieurs milliers de
victimes dans certains coins de la terre
à mi-course mais tout est très chaude et
free crostis très chaud winnie notes et
est beau territoire dans les bureaux
d'exxon aux états unis on s'inquiète
quelques semaines plus tard un document
circule annonciateur de toute la
stratégie pour les années à venir
l'effet de serre dit ce mémo pourrait
devenir l'un des enjeux environnementaux
majeurs des années 90 les principaux gaz
à effet de serre son produit par la
combustion des énergies fossiles et
surtout cette phrase la position de la
compagnie
et d'insister sur l'incertitude
scientifique entourant une possible
augmentation de l'effet de serre
exxon a su il y à des décennies que ces
produits pourraient menacer le climat de
la planète
et lorsque vous mettez dans les mains
c'est la preuve que hésité à l'avance de
bien des chercheurs qui travaillait dans
le domaine à cette époque là et malgré
ça la compagnie est accusé d'avoir semé
le doute dans le débat
un double discours qui va résonner
jusqu'aux canada
[Musique]
c'est ici que je range mon vieux casque
et ma combinaison travail des souvenirs
d'une époque excitante pour être gavé
1979 il vient à peine de terminer son
baccalauréat en génie chimique
ils sillonnent les eaux chaudes du golfe
du mexique à bord d'un pétrolier d'exxon
le s aux athlétiques
ça me rappelle une belle période de ma
vie stimulante intellectuellement
dessiné les plans
l'instrumentation prend des nouvelles
mesures de dioxyde de carbone
ce que personne jamais fait avant
surveillez les océans
ça me rappelle de bons souvenirs
[Musique]
travailler chez exante c'était
formidable
la compagnie était tournée vers l'avenir
et leurs divisions de recherche était
l'une des meilleures au monde
edgar v était responsable d'un projet de
recherche visant à mieux comprendre le
rôle des océans dans l'absorption du
dioxyde de carbone un des gaz à effet de
serre dans ce but un laboratoire avait
été aménagé sur ce géant des mers
c'était le quatrième bateau en
importance au monde
énorme une véritable île flottante
l'ensemble où une grande partie de
l'entreprise était très impliqué c'était
une période d'activité intense pour les
scientifiques d'exxon ils menaient aussi
les recherches sur les énergies
renouvelables comme les panneaux
solaires et les batteries au lithium et
aussi sur les modèles climatiques
je crois que c'est une stratégie
défensive mais pas pour cacher le
problème c'était plutôt ça risque d'être
un problème pour l'industrie des
énergies fossiles
alors nous voulons que nos scientifiques
contribuer à la recherche pour être
entendus lorsque les discussions sur ce
qu'il faut faire comment seront moi je
suis un peu tombé dans les changements
climatiques comme obélix dans la potion
magique parce que je voulais faire un
doctorat aux états unis en écologie
catherine pots-de-vin a commencé à
s'intéresser aux changements climatiques
en 1982 par le biais des plantes
la biologiste se rendre à jusque dans la
brousse panaméenne pour étudier leur
réaction à l'augmentation du dioxyde de
carbone dans l'atmosphère
c'était quand même une problématique qui
était connue donc il y avait quand même
beaucoup de chercheurs un peu partout
dans le monde qui essayait à la fois de
comprendre aux qui ce gaz le change dans
sa concentration
pourquoi puis quel est le lien de sang
avec la biosphère pis quel est le lien
de 5 le climat
les chercheurs dixon était à la fine
pointe de ses recherches
ce mémo envoyé aux gestionnaires de la
compagnie en 1982 fait partie des
documents déterré lord enquête
journalistique aux états unis ce
graphique prédit très bien
l'augmentation observée aujourd'hui des
concentrations de dioxyde de carbone
dans l'atmosphère et des températures
je vous passe ça c'est un document de
1982 envoyé au management d'exxon aux
états unis oui ça sera coach savait plus
que ben des scientifiques
vous n'aviez pas tant que ça en 1982 moi
je probablement que je connaissais moins
précisément les projections des modèles
climatiques que ce que tu dis si et
lorsque vous mettez dans les mains si la
preuve que is it et al avance de bien
des chercheurs qui travaillait dans le
domaine à cette époque là
citant des experts le mémo indique que
des événements catastrophiques doivent
être envisagée et que lorsqu'il sera
possible de mesurer les impacts de
l'effet de serre ces impacts seront
peut-être irait vers celle des impacts
que la compagnie essaie déjà de mesurer
au canada les périodes les méthodes et
fiers du rôle prépondérant qu'elle a
joué dans l'exploitation pétrolière au
canada la filiale d'exxon l'impérial à
qui appartient la bannière esso est
présente depuis plus de 140 ans au
canada et prend de fioul tout heureux
car non même pas non même pas pendant
longtemps c'était la marque de pétrole
au pays le pétrole amorcé dès 1964 un
vaste programme d'exploration dans
l'arctique canadien
après avoir consacré dix années et plus
de 100 millions de dollars
elle a trouvé le grand gisement
d'énergie que la lumière la compagnie
est une pionnière de l'exploration en
arctique allant jusqu'à construire des
îles artificielles pour chercher le
pétrole dès 1989 au moment où sa société
mère insiste sur l'incertitude entourant
les changements climatiques
l'impériale s'inquiètent des impacts
possibles dans cette région elle
commande une étude pour savoir si un
éventuel dégel du pergélisol pourrait
nuire à ses projets de pipelines dans la
vallée de la rivière mckenzie dans les
territoires du nord ouest
elle sera même partenaire privilégié
d'environnement canada pour des
recherches climatiques dans cette région
ses souhaits cohen qui dirigeait cette
grande étude l'étude couvre le nord de
la colombie britannique de l'alberta de
la saskatchewan est presque toute la
vallée jusqu'à la merde on constatait
déjà dans les années 80 que la vallée du
mackenzie se réchauffer plus vite que
n'importe quel autre endroit au pays
c'est pour ça qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'intérêt les équipes de steve mcqueen
et de l'impérial décide donc de joindre
leurs forces
il comprenait à quel point c'était il
voulait faire partie du projet ils ont
offert leur expertise et leur
contribution financière
j'appréciais beaucoup leur aide il était
sérieux
la relation a été très bonne jusqu'à la
fin de 1992 puis un jour ce week-end
n'arrive soudainement plus à joindre
personne dans les bureaux de l'impériale
est puissant trop d'avertissements
ils se sont retirés ils ont disparu
comme ça ils ont arrêté de prendre vos
appels exactement
et je ne pense pas que c'était le choix
de l'équipe technique avec laquelle je
travaille et ce n'est pas ce qu'il
voulait ils se sont fait dire désolé il
faut laisser tomber le projet mon
principal contact m'a dit que c'était un
ordre de la direction qui ne voulait
plus faire de recherche sur les
changements climatiques
ce taux est qu elle a l'impression que
l'industrie s'est retrouvé face à deux
choix existentiels je crois que certains
dans l'industrie ont compris qu'ils
pouvaient être menacée et qu'il fallait
s'en occuper malheureusement ils ont
fait le choix de s'opposer à la science
[Musique]
après la pause les révélations
étonnantes de l'ancien ministre de
l'environnement shiloh cops confronté un
lobby pétrolier effluents je fais un peu
naïf aussi
[Musique]
plusieurs écologistes prétendre que les
ministres de l'environnement n'ont pas
beaucoup de poids au sein de leur
gouvernement
surtout quand ils veulent vraiment poser
des gestes qui vont contre les intérêts
de l'industrie pétrolière alors on est
allé voir des ex des ex ministre de
l'environnement
ils confirment les premières ministre
les ministres de l'environnement
j'étais content tu voulais être ministre
de l'environnement avait probablement
été un peu naïf aussi eye cherry coop
city souhaiterait aussi fait faux parce
que je connaissais moins comment le
maniement du canada dépend des sur les
revenus des pétroliers
lorsque sheila copps est nommé ministre
de l'environnement en 1993
sa mission est claire donner suite aux
engagements pris un an plus tôt par le
canada à rio au début des années 90
l'heure est à la mobilisation
internationale sur le front des
changements climatiques
une période qui culmine avec ce grand
sommet de la terre à rio
[Musique]
l'homme d'après rios doit aussi aimé le
monde
tout cet environnement naturel que nous
détruisons régulièrement
les participants à la conférence adopte
une première convention cadre sur les
changements climatiques
bien qu'il n'y ait aucune mesure
contraignante à l'époque on parlait
beaucoup du principe de précaution
quand on pense que y an un danger
possible
on est mieux de prévenir que de faire
face à la catastrophe
pour remplir les promesses faites par le
précédent gouvernement mulroney à rio
le parti libéral du canada s'était donné
des objectifs ambitieux réduire d'ici
2005 de 20% ses émissions de gaz à effet
de serre par rapport aux niveaux de 1990
quand je me suis rendu à ma première
réunion avec monsieur ministre il m'a
dit madame parce que j'ai dit est ce un
ami sur promesse de 20% et dit madame ça
c'est la politique maintenant vous êtes
dans le gouvernement
le gouvernement n'est pas la politique
alors même que vous avez fait cette
promesse l'a oublié parce que vous ne
leur est pas forcément subi ce qui m'a
dit ça mais avant de continuer avec
sheila copps
il faut comprendre ce qui se passait
dans l'industrie de l'autre côté de la
frontière
car ces développements vont avoir un
impact au canada aux états unis dans les
années 90 la riposte s'organise des
scientifiques liées aux industries vont
s'attaquer à la science des changements
climatiques et s'opposer à des mesures
restrictives
chez ericsson
le discours s'est durcie davantage avec
l'arrivée de nouveaux grands patrons
lieberman jusqu'en 2004 il maintiendra
que toutes sortes de facteurs cause des
changements climatiques mais qu'on ne
sait toujours pas si l'activité humaine
y joue un rôle dans les années 70 et 80
les données scientifiques étaient
suffisantes pour éviter cet argument
cela démontre une incapacité à
comprendre la science c'est du déni au
canada la proche de la filiale
l'impériale est plus nuancé durant la
première moitié des années 90 la
compagnie insiste sur les risques
économiques d'éventuelles mesures
gouvernementales mais elle reconnaît
publiquement que le problème est réel
john quinn a été à l'emploi de
l'impérial dans les années 70 puis il a
travaillé sur les questions
environnementales au sein du
gouvernement fédéral
l'impériale reconnu publiquement au
début des années 90 la validité de la
science des changements climatiques que
les changements seraient réels et qu'il
pourrait avoir un impact mais durant le
passage de sheila copps à
l'environnement les prises de position
de l'impérial vont progressivement
s'aligner sur celle d'exxon
malgré ses connaissances avancées alain
terme sur les changements climatiques le
discours public de la compagnie va
changer plusieurs d'entre nous avons
constaté je dirais une ex ionisation
progressive la compagnie pas seulement
parce qu'il y avait plus de costard gris
mais dans ses prises de position
publiques
exxon ne voulait pas reconnaître que le
climat allait avoir un impact sur ces
affaires
cette politique c'est de plus en plus
refléter au canada un ancien haut
dirigeant de l'impérial encore très
proche de l'industrie confirment qu'à
compter de 1995
les politiques environnementales de la
compagnie devait être révisée au texas
et que des mots comme développement
durable et est dorénavant banni les
premiers conseils on vous avait donné
c'est de vous rendre au meeting de ce
qui s'appelait le friday
dès le début de son mandat sheila copps
découvre qu'un comité composé de
lobbyistes et de représentants des
grandes industries dont lé père jan est
très présent le fera et d'égout et il
voulait que je rejoins à ce groupe pour
savoir c'est quoi les pensées de l'autre
côté mais ce que dans ce que le friday
groupe il y en avait les les industries
liste mais on n'avait jamais de faire
des groupes d les environnementalistes
ce groupe informel se réunit plusieurs
fois par année à ottawa politiciens et
fonctionnaires sont invités à sa table
mais selon sheila copps le froid et des
groupes organisés sur tout la contre
attaque dans les dossiers
environnementaux
j'ai fait deux trois réunions giddish de
plus en faire parce que c'est un père de
menton je peux pas leur convaincre quoi
que ce soit puis arrivait juste me faire
pression de ne rien faire
la ministre réalise aussi que
l'industrie peut compter sur l'appui
solide des ministères économiques
particulièrement les ressources
naturelles et qu'il pèse beaucoup plus
aux cabinets le ministère de
l'environnement est isolé
si j'étais supposé de l'île de man le
cabinet pour avoir un mandat de
réduction pour les changements
climatiques
c'est les ministres qui se réunissait
pour et sait comment est-ce qu'on peut
freiner sa et uil travail avec les lots
bs l'une des batailles va se jouer
autour de la question des mesures
volontaires ou non pour amener
l'industrie à réduire ses émissions
sheila copps veut des réglementations
forte l'industrie et la ministre des
ressources naturelles
heinonen veulent des mesures volontaires
c'est aussi à cette période que
l'impériale à l'instar de sa société
mère américaine exxon commencent à
remettre en question la science des
changements climatiques à instiller le
doute dans le débat
nous avons retrouvé cette lettre de 1994
aux archives nationales du canada
elle a été envoyée par le pdg de
l'impérial à plusieurs ministres
l'incertitude scientifique entourant les
changements climatiques dutil commande
une retenue de la part du gouvernement
toute action interventionniste
risquerait de causer un dommage social
et économique
la question était de savoir comment
réduire les gaz à effet de serre tout en
protégeant l'économie personne n'a
travaillé là dessus
chacun essayait de tirer de son côté a
vu me lazhar travaillait comme haut
fonctionnaire au ministère de
l'environnement à l'époque responsable
notamment du dossier des changements
climatiques
ce fut un échec complet parce que
l'industrie a senti que le gouvernement
n'était pas prêt à agir
il avait raison nous n'avons toujours
pas agi selon sheila copps
l'une des raisons était que les lobbys
était beaucoup plus puissants du côté de
l'industrie que celui des
environnementalistes
c'est ce que découvre plus tard l'un et
l'autre question que nous avions à part
évidemment c'est la question de si les
revenus viennent de ce groupe black très
fortement dans les coffres du parlement
mais ça crée pas mal de problèmes pour
avoir le courage de se retirer de ses
profits
en 1995 comme le souhaitait l'industrie
et l'alberta c'est un registre
volontaire des émissions qui est mis sur
pieds sensibles ni échéancier pour y
arriver je sais que l'industrie
informellement ont écrit en lettre au
premier ministre en disant que j'étais
très déraisonnable et dit je dois être
déplacée par un autre vraiment oui oui
oui
quoi qu'il en soit trois ans après son
arrivée sheila copps changera de
ministères l'environnement fut l'un des
postes les plus difficiles de sa
carrière politique
quand j'étais à l'intérieur et je
luttais oui ça me faisait vraiment
frustré parce que nous avions promis de
faire ces choses-là près d'une décennie
sera perdu mais la vraie bataille est à
venir et l'impérial l'ancien leader de
l'industrie en recherche climatique va
adopter un discours de plus en plus
climato sceptiques
il se trouve que je suis plutôt d'accord
avec les gens du côté vert mais je pense
que l'industrie a le droit de défendre
ses intérêts maintenant s'ils mentent
ils dénaturent les faits ça ce n'est pas
éthique et c'est légitime politiquement
au retour un autre ministre de
l'environnement nous raconte comment il
a été prise à partie par un patron de
l'industrie pétrolière il était si
agressif lors de cette rencontre que je
vais vraiment peu envie de le rencontrer
à nouveau d'être encore malmenées
[Musique]
c'était surprenant d'entendre sheila
copps nous révéler à quel point les
promesses politiques de lutte aux
changements climatiques n'étaient
parfois justement que ça que des
promesses et bien attendez de voir la
bataille qui s'est jouée en coulisses
autour de l'accord de kyoto
[Musique]
ça faisait dix jours que dave henderson
avait été nommé ministre fédéral de
l'environnement
son mandat faire enfin avancer le
dossier des changements climatiques en
ou 1999 il se rend à car grille pour une
rencontre avec des représentants de
l'industrie du gaz et du pétrole
il s'attend à un simple premier contact
social
ça devait être une petite rencontre
amical bonjour et cetera ça ne devait
pas être le genre de réunion pour
discuter en profondeur dans jeux
scientifiques mais il est surpris par
l'attitude d'un des participants qui le
prend tout de suite à partie à propos
des changements climatiques
il m'a dit que la science se tromper
qu'ils le savent parce que la capacité
intellectuelle de leurs scientifiques
leur permet de nous dire qu'on a tort il
était si agressif lors de cette
rencontre que je vais vraiment peu envie
de le rencontrer à nouveau d'être encore
malmenées cet homme c'est le pdg de
l'intérieur
après avoir gravi les échelons de la
compagnie il en a pris les rênes en 1992
un peu avant que rappelez vous dansiez
employés et noté un durcissement une
expo nisation de la position de la
compagnie sur la question des
changements climatiques a été l'un des
promoteurs les plus ardents des sables
bitumineux dans les années 70 et 80
leur énorme potentiel est connue depuis
longtemps mais de nouvelles technologies
permettent d'y accéder de façon moins
coûteuse
au tournant des années 2000 l'impériale
avec d'autres compagnies investissent
des milliards de dollars dans ce nouvel
eldorado de bonne nouvelle pour les
actionnaires
l'ennui c'est que malgré les efforts de
l'industrie pour le rendre moins
polluants un baril de pétrole issu des
sables bitumineux est en général
beaucoup plus néfastes pour le climat
cabarry pétrole conventionnel un fait
difficilement compatible avec les
objectifs de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre du canada
ça faisait des décennies que le canada
avait décidé que son avenir économique
c'était les sables bitumineux
leyio comme un gros problème que les
sables bitumineux et le canada
évidemment peau était très enthousiaste
et n'est toujours pas très enthousiaste
face au problème principal que le pays
auxquels le pays doit faire face en 1997
la communauté internationale se réunit à
kyoto pour s'attaquer au changement
climatique les enjeux cette fois ci sont
majeurs ont vu négocier une première
entente contraignante pour réduire les
gaz à effet de serre le canada comme
chaque pays signataire doit maintenant
élaborer un plan de match pour atteindre
ces objectifs et ratifié le protocole
monsieur chrétien ma confie
l'environnement avec le mandat de
m'assurer que l'accord de kyoto soit
ratifié ensuite il m'a dit on va voir ce
qu'on peut faire maintenant et c'est
comme ça que j'ai entrepris une tournée
pour récolter des appuis
tandis que des vedettes de sun
entreprend sa tournée du pays les
opposants à l'accord s'organise et l'un
des critiques les plus implacables de
kyoto et le pdg de l'impérial mais le
patron de l'impérial va plus loin il
multiplie les déclarations sceptique sur
le réchauffement de la planète
en s'attaquant à ses fondements
scientifiques comme il l'a fait avec le
ministre ndèye sène le dioxyde de
carbone n'est pas un polluant mais un
ingrédient essentiel à la vie sur cette
planète écrit-il dans le journal la
compagnie en 1998 le lien dit il entre
la combustion des énergies fossiles et
les changements climatiques
demeure une hypothèse non prouvée d'une
certaine façon il est allé à l'encontre
de la position antérieure de la
compagnie il a remis en question la
science du changement climatique ou le
rôle qu'ils jouent les humains alors il
ya eu un virage et honnêtement je ne
peux pas vous dire s'il s'agissait de sa
propre vision ou 6 et exxon qui
commençait à imposer la sienne en 2002
au plus fort du débat entourant l'accord
de kyoto
l'impérial et d'autres compagnies vont
jusqu'à financer une conférence de
climato-sceptiques reconnu la corde qui
auto distille et partiale et basée sur
des arguments non fondées ouaddou au
moins ya quelque chose de
fondamentalement malhonnête a toujours
essayé de dire il en faut plus plus de
connaissances et c'est ce qu'il ya comme
cherche aujourd'hui toujours plus de
connaissances on peut toujours pouvoir
rendre nos modèles plus précis mais dès
le début des années 2000 on savait qu'il
y avait un problème
ce qu'on savait moins c'est que même si
l'impérial sème le doute publiquement
sur les changements climatiques
alain terne elle les prend au sérieux
lorsque vient le temps de construire le
projet sable au large de la nouvelle
écosse
en 1996 les plans de ce projet mené par
plusieurs compagnies prévoient d
ajustement pour tenir compte de la
hausse du niveau de la mer due au
réchauffement de la planète à toutes nos
questions concernant ses archives et
sable l'impérial nous a simplement
répondu que cela reflétait les
discussions de l'époque
concernant l'évolution de la science des
changements climatiques et les
politiques pour réduire les émissions
mais à l'époque il n'y a pas que
l'impériale qui est réfractaire à kyoto
une grande partie du milieu des affaires
canadien aussi on va utiliser des
arguments nationalistes et économique
pour s'y attaquer en octobre 2002 une
nouvelle formule circulent il faut une
solution proprement canadienne pour
s'attaquer aux changements climatiques
le dirigeant de l'impériale est l'un des
premiers dans l'industrie à l'utiliser
l'expression est employée lors d'une
campagne intensive lancé par un
regroupement d'associations de plusieurs
industries et sera reprise par des
politiciens
elle créera de la confusion au sein de
la population mais elle fera mouche
un sondage publié durant cette période
révèle que le soutien pour kyoto s'érode
45% des répondants souhaitent que le
gouvernement favorise une solution
proprement canadienne plutôt que kyoto
nous avions un appui très fort dans tout
le pays et sa vessie suite à cette
campagne de l'industrie
[Musique]
malgré cela le 10 décembre 2002 après
une dure bataille des jeunes de sun voit
ses efforts récompensés
c'est l'un des grands moments de ma
carrière en politique j'ai travaillé
presque à temps plein sur les enjeux
climatiques
nous avons obtenu 60 % ou plus des votes
alors je me suis précipité vers monsieur
chrétien pour lui serrer la main car il
m'a beaucoup appuyé mais tout bon
citoyen du monde soit il le canada tient
toujours à ces sables bitumineux
le ministre des ressources naturelles
rassure vite l'industrie le gouvernement
veillera à ce que les coûts liés à kyoto
demeure minime pour elle
moi [ __ ]
la plus grande des trolls hier au pays
sun power affirme que ces coûts
additionnels ne sont que de 20 à 27
cents par baril de pétrole négligeable
dit m c'est un enjeu crucial de
nombreuses vies humaines pourrait être
en jeu
je suis en colère parce que ça a été
bloqué par des gens qui ne cherchait que
des gains à court terme
pourquoi 10 20 30 ans
entre 1995 et 2004 la production dans
les sables bitumineux va plus que
doubler notre enquête se poursuit dans
un instant avec les rencontres secrètes
et surprenante entre l'industrie
pétrolière et des environnementalistes
que certaines compagnies pétrolières
l'idée de nous rencontrer et moins et
d'autres environnementalistes c'était
une trahison
[Musique]
on dirait que depuis toujours les
positions des militants écologistes et
de l'industrie pétrolière sont
irréconciliables qui sont à couteaux
tirés
mais saviez-vous qu'ils ont déjà tenté
de s'entendre on vous amène dans une
rencontre secrète le va et vient des
bateaux dans la baie de brown à
vancouver des bateaux souvent remplis de
gaz et de pétrole
pour l'environnementaliste support our
man cette scène évoque la menace
climatique et le combat de sa vie pour
s'y attaquer le premier ministre harper
avait fait un discours en grande
bretagne que je n'oublierai jamais on
commençait tous à réaliser l'ampleur des
changements climatiques
ces ports à bergen avait quitté le pays
durant quelques années pour diriger le
programme sur les changements
climatiques de greenpeace international
mais en 2012 inquiète de l'essor des
sables bitumineux
elle décide de revenir au canada on
commençait tous à comprendre à quel
point le problème était grave et le
premier ministre harper en grande
bretagne annonce que le canada va
devenir une superpuissance énergétique
depuis le milieu des années 2000 le
canada et ses sables bitumineux sont
devenus les bêtes noires des
environnementalistes et des célébrités
du monde entier
la pression est forte
ouais
encore plus lorsque le gouvernement
conservateur de stephen harper retire le
canada de l'accord de kyoto
je ne pouvais penser qu'au débat au
canada autour des sables bitumineux avec
un petit groupe de personnes sport
habermann va tenter ce que personne
depuis 25 ans n'a réussi à s'entendre
avec l'industrie pour encadrer le
développement pétrolier en alberta elle
était déjà parvenu à le faire avec des
compagnies forestières
j'ai été arrêtée j'ai fait face à huit
cent cinquante sept chefs d'accusation
d'incitation de complicité je risquais
six ans de prison
j'avais 23 ans après un moment les deux
camps ennemis accepte de se rencontrer
et le dialogue mène à une entente
historique pour préserver la forêt
vierge en colombie-britannique quelqu'un
suggère à l'environnementaliste de
tenter un rapprochement semblable avec
les producteurs pétroliers
une rencontre est organisée avec le
président de leur association
ce fut parmi les conversations les plus
fascinantes que j'ai jamais eu de si tu
reconnais la science des changements
climatiques quelles seraient selon toi
notre juste part
que devrait faire le canada
d'autres groupes environnementaux et
cinq des plus grandes pétrolières
canadiennes vont bientôt se joindre aux
discussions
les rencontres ont lieu en secret dans
des salles privées de restaurants sur
certaines compagnies pétrolières l'idée
de nous rencontrer et moins et d'autres
environnementalistes c'était une
trahison
ça aurait été une histoire explosive au
début l'impériale est présent de ces
réunions mais ça ne durera pas à un
moment donné et nous ont dit que le
siège social aux états unis ne veux pas
qu'on continue ses conversations et nous
ont dit nous ne pousserons pas le
gouvernement à adopter des politiques
plus sévères sur les changements
climatiques prévue en 2015
coup de tonnerre politique les
albertains élisent un gouvernement
néo-démocrate décidé à s'attaquer aux
changements climatiques
les discussions entamées par le groupe
de type aura bergman vont se poursuivre
dans ce cadre provinciale élargie et en
novembre 2015
l'alberta conclu un accord historique
pour contrôler le développement des
sables bitumineux
il y avait de l'électricité dans l'air
les gens pleuraient
je pensais jamais que je verrai ce jour
c'était pas mal excitant de day will
stop
en plus de fixer un plafond global pour
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
ce qui n'avait jamais été fait l'entente
prévoit une taxe carbone à la pompe et
l'abandon progressif du charbon mais à
l'époque c'est déjà trop pour le nouveau
patron de l'impérial reach google ne
veut surtout rien savoir d'un plafond
global d'émission l'entente créer un
schisme au sein de l'industrie
[Musique]
j'ai entendu dire qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de réunions ça s'engueule est pas mal je
dirais que compte tenu de la position
d'exxon sur les changements climatiques
à l'époque les périodes ne pouvait pas
se joindre à la coalition parce qu'ils
avaient de grands projets d'expansion
ce plafond inacceptable pour l'impérial
était pourtant très généreux selon
l'ancien ministre des voeux dans deux
semaines par exemple le plan permettait
beaucoup plus des missions liées au gaz
et au pétrole qu'est ce que l'industrie
et mettait à cette époque ces ports
haben reconnaît que l'entente albertaine
n'était qu'un premier pas et aux non ce
n'était pas suffisant pour atteindre les
objectifs de paris ce n'était pas assez
fort pour limiter la production des
sables bitumineux
mais c'était une politique climatique
force
quoi qu'il en soit le gouvernement note
les n'adoptera jamais la réglementation
pour implanter le plafond d'émissions et
durant la campagne électorale qui suit
l'entente est séparable mines sont
férocement attaqué
les conservateurs sont élus en 2019 et
tout espoir pour des actions majeures
sur les changements climatiques en
alberta et perdu les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ont augmenté de près de
20 % au canada depuis 1990 et la
production des sables bitumineux elle a
grimpé de cinq cent soixante cinq pour
cent entre 1992 et 2000 16 le 19 octobre
un comité du congrès américain se penche
sur ce qu'il appelle les efforts de
l'industrie pétrolière pour cacher la
vérité sur les changements climatiques
est grave et les chercheurs dixon est
présent il est important de savoir que
les compagnies pétrolières étaient au
courant de ceci depuis des décennies que
les dénis et tout ce qui est survenu par
la suite n'existait pas avant
ont discuté de la façon de faire face au
changement climatique
pas si c'était vrai ou non dans un
courriel
exxon mobil nous écrit que les
allégations concernant sa recherche sur
le climat sont fausses et délibérément
trompeuse
les déclarations soigneusement
sélectionnés attribuer un petit nombre
d'employés suggère à tort que des
conclusions avaient été tirées des
décennies plus tôt dit elle
[Musique]
exxonmobil nous souligne qu'elle a gagné
un premier procès dans l'état de new
york une cause assez pointue où on lui
reprochait d'avoir dupé ses actionnaires
sur le vrai coût des changements
climatiques
le juge dit la compagnie a conclu que
les témoignages ont démontré qu'une
culture vigoureuse d' analyse de
planification de comptabilité et de
communication existent chez exxon mobil
mais une vingtaine d'autres poursuites
lancées contre aix en est d'autres
pétrolières sont toujours actives des
états américains et des municipalités
comme charlton les accuse d'avoir trompé
le public sur les dommages causés par
leurs produits tu vas tu
axsun est tellement une grande compagnie
à ce moment là c'était la plus grande
compagnie au monde alors ça aurait pu
faire partie de leur rôle de guide et
l'industrie la compagnie était assez
puissante pour le faire s'ils l'avaient
choisi george quinn crois que
l'impériale aussi à une influence sur le
débat au canada
je pense qu'ils ont utilisé leur poids
pour bloquer vous pourrez poser un
consensus parmi leurs pairs se fit très
important cela a eu un impact ensuite
sur leur lot b et sur leur message
auprès des gouvernements
je blâme l'industrie mais aussi le
gouvernement de ne pas s'être montré
plus ferme envers les ressources
naturelles ou d'autres ministères qui
s'opposaient aux mesures pour s'attaquer
aux changements climatiques qui pensait
c'est pas dans l'intérêt de nos clients
donc pas dans les nôtres n'ont plus les
périodes nous a écrit qu'elle appuie
l'accord de paris et qu'elle travaille
avec les gouvernements pour réduire les
émissions au plus bas coût possible pour
la société grâce à des investissements
majeurs en recherche
elle ajoute avoir déjà réduit ses
émissions par baril de pétrole de 20% et
elle compte les diminuer encore de 10%
d'ici 2023
[Musique]
l'année a été désastreuse pour exxon est
la filiale canadienne l'impérial chute
du prix du baril de pétrole
et puis la crise la coved mais
ultimement c'est peut-être le marché lui
même qui va freiner les ambitions de la
compagnie dans les sables bitumineux
à l'époque je pense que l'impériale
pensait qu'un front uni est absolument
essentiel pour bloquer les politiques
sur les changements climatiques
je pense qu'ils ont perdu cette bataille
les principales banques disent que les
sables bitumineux du canada seront les
premiers produits pétroliers à être
tranchée du marché en raison de leurs
émissions carbone et de leur prix élevé
il n'y a pas si longtemps
exxon avait la plus grande valeur
boursière au monde
[Musique]
en août dernier elle a été éjectée du
célèbre indices boursiers dow jones
[Musique]
pour catherine pots-de-vin on ne peut
plus perdre de temps
c'est sûr qu'il ya deux avenues qui
s'offrent à nous via l'avenue ok on voit
investir dans une reprise plus verte où
on va faire ce qu'on faisait avant je
continue ma recherche fondamentale mais
mais la prise de décision politique
l'action des gens leur parler pour que
les gens comprennent l'urgence critique
terrifiante de ça c'est devenu de plus
en plus obsédants pour moi
[Musique]
j'espère que vous avez apprécié notre
reportage de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]